all right Shane yes Shane where are you
from originally I'm from uh Palmdale
California Palmdale yes sir and tell me
about your family growing up they
weren't really there like they never
wanted to listen when we used to tell
them like something was wrong they
didn't want to hear it when I told my
mom I got raped she didn't want to
believe me
it was hard this is your biological
appearance yeah and then we got put into
foster care and got separated and when
we got separated it kind of like left a
mental state of mind on me because
we they were we were separated you know
and with getting raped at six years old
and 13 it's kind of hard because when
your parents don't believe you about
somebody who's like in the family who's
doing it it's hard because you have to
see that person every day and you're
just like what to do what to do you know
that went on for how long uh like four
years
and nobody did anything about it no
and it's like they wouldn't send us to
school sometimes because we would have
bruises on us or
they wouldn't we wouldn't allowed to go
around people because we had bruises on
us and then when we finally did go to
school like they seen like the marks on
it so and they're mandated reporters so
they just called themselves
so the sexual abuse happened with your
biological parents yeah not with the
Foster no we got foster care that's when
we got raped again
it was a two thing yeah it was a
two-time like occurrence
and then they they held me down and made
what raped my little sister made me
watch
and who did this to you uh the foster
parents
it was crazy like I have dreams about it
too still every day like
it's like post-traumatic stress track
traumatic flashbacks where's your sister
now
um she's in Bakersfield
is she doing all right or she she's
she's she's
healing she's healing she's healing
you know it's crazy
and then I got pregnant I had the baby
and
they took the baby from me
so this was from the rape yes
it's hard like it's crazy
you went to high school I I never
finished
they took us out of school and put us in
like uh Opportunity School like a like a
homeschool type [__]
because they didn't want us around
people because they they were scared
that we was going to run away tell
somebody you know and it needs to be
told because it's not cool at all like
it's not cool
how old are you now 27 27.
yeah
and you've been living on the streets
now how long five years
drug zero part of your life I assume uh
not really anymore mainly Weed and
Alcohol
because it numbs the pain better than
drugs do really yeah and I'm afraid to
get fentanyl so right I don't want to
you know you're smart to avoid that yeah
I don't do Fentanyl but alcohol is your
thing yeah like my mom yeah
how bad do you drink like every day like
but I'm trying to really quit because I
have a stomach ulcer too so
I'm just
I don't know it's like a blackout drunk
or no no never I'm always focused like
I just drink the numb the pain like just
the thought of everything that I've been
through you're living without a tent
yeah I'm going back and forth like here
and there like I call 2-1-1 to get
vouchers but they gave it to me for like
a week and that was it and I'm like
how do you make money
but anyway I can
like I wouldn't call it prostitution I
would just calling it everybody's got to
eat at the end of the day you know and
not things that I'm proud of definitely
not you know and I wish if I could
reverse time I would go back and change
some [__]
because I wouldn't wish that on anybody
and I don't want anybody going down
those paths who've never been down those
paths because it's scary yeah but that
was out of your control yeah it is
there's nothing you could have done
about it no not really at that age no
they didn't believe us anyway
right
and your biological parents lost you for
that reason they lost yeah they lost me
us for that and then they lost us for um
not putting us in school like it was
like a lack of attendance in the school
so they you know they came
but it was crazy when they came because
they had everything that they needed we
had a bed we had food we had heating you
know we had the basic [__] like
and they still don't believe us I'm like
okay so it was just like who do I tell
what do I do like
and
yeah so now you're on Skid Row yeah yeah
I try not to like be around schedule I
try to like go back and forth to the
places because downtown L.A is very
dangerous like
and everybody all they want to do is
[__] like that's ever you know what I
mean and it's not like it's like how is
it benefiting me you know like I'm like
I'm good
like I'm just trying to get my [__]
right I just
I just try to pray every day things get
better
put them dreams them dreams is What
Hurts the Most it's because it's visual
like what I dream it's visual you know
and that [__] hurt like
it's just it sucks like
you have just one child
he would have been well he he's gonna be
uh
eight nine nine nine in January
next year anyway
did you ever feel loved by any of your
family no because I was mixed like my
mom she's white Puerto Rican and my
dad's Native American and black so with
my long side of the family
they judge me because I was like mixed
color like I was the first scrap baby
mix
and so the reason why they were mad at
her they were taking out on me like
but no I don't I don't feel I don't even
know like what love truly is
I don't even know that [__] like
it sucks
because I really didn't ask to be born
you know I didn't ask to be here
I didn't ask for all that [__]
I just I guess I gotta let go let God
and just you know it's my life like I
gotta deal with it
what do you worry about most now
how the baby's doing
and if I'm gonna wake up tomorrow
because of being in the streets and [__]
like
that's what I'm really worried about
it's scary it's scary
and if I could rewind time like I said I
would go back and change a lot of [__]
like
and maybe I would get a different result
today but I don't so I just
try to cope with it you know
that's where the alcohol helps
that's where it helps
and the weed helps me sleep at night
kind of like
do you have any anyone you trust nobody
I don't even trust myself at times
that's the scary part
because sometimes some days you just
want to give up some days you just don't
know what to do some piece you know
do you feel like you deserve a better
life than this yeah because it's like
honestly I didn't deserve what I went
through as a child either and I didn't
know my parents were going to be good
enough parents to take care of something
that they created
you know thank you and it sucks like
how are you gonna make a baby and not
take care of it
like that's a responsibility and if you
lay down to make a baby you should take
care of it not just abandon it just like
a dog or a cat like
if you have an animal don't throw it to
the streets because you get tired like
it's crazy
do you have any good memories of your
life
I mean
just being around my sibling like trying
to make sure my little sister was okay
we had our good times together like we
you know but not really my childhood we
were like forced to grow up I guess you
would call it I don't know
because I don't remember nothing really
in my childhood with the rape and [__]
we went through with the foster care
and then getting separated that [__] and
then
yeah that's crazy
how did you first get into drugs
uh the streets
and you were on the streets at what age
it started being on the streets at like
21 22. so fairly late
I think but I knew it was coming sooner
or later because
it was starting to go slowly with my
family they were starting to like you
know like they're all like okay good
night
and it just fully went full pledge like
quick like a blink of an eye like
Life Changes in a blink of an eye you're
here one day gone tomorrow you know like
it's good you were able to steer away
from fentanyl though yeah I don't I
don't I don't never did it and I never
want to try it like
I've done crystal meth and I really like
it because I didn't like being up
you know I've done ecstasy I didn't like
it because
[__] was just too bright like you know
what I mean I've done shrooms and I
didn't like the walls breathing at me a
little scary
so I'm just like oh [__] and Coke like
I don't like my nose being numb
so we like you know I did Dibble the
devil but
my honestly choice of drug is Weed and
Alcohol like and cigarettes that's it
but but I eat and sleep and [__] like
you know what I mean like so it's not
like I'm depriving myself of food and
nutrients because that's not what I
don't do I try not to at least you know
I guess that's a comfort thing too like
me and my little snacks but
would you describe yourself as
self-destructive yeah it can be
it's hard not to be with it yeah it is
because it hurts it hurts especially
when I go to sleep them dreams like
they're so visual
it's like a life like it's like a movie
playing before your eyes but when you're
asleep like it's everything that you
went through this is in your dreams or
yeah it's it's called Uh
uh reoccurring reoccurring nightmares
that's what it's called you can you can
look it up to like it's a whole
definition on what it is
that's exactly what I had to reoccurring
because I would get this same dream and
then the next night I'll get the same
dream but only part of the dream
and then the next night I wouldn't have
the dream the next night the Dream came
back and it was a different part I'm
like what the [__] like so it really
threw off my sleep schedule I didn't
want to sleep I was scared to go to
sleep I didn't want to go to sleep
because I didn't want to see that I
didn't want to go to sleep because of
this and that like that's where I
started like like getting sleep deprived
I guess and this
it's just one thing after another and
it's like I'm permanently gonna be
[__] up from it because it's a mental
thing
and that's why it's like
you can't love until you love yourself
and it's hard to love myself because of
what I went through so it's like it's
hard for me to love somebody like and
that's not cool like
it's not cool at all
but then again in another state it's
funny you know but it's not it's like
okay
it's gonna be a lonely life though not
having
any friends or anyone
because he wasn't allowed to I wasn't
allowed to I believe even even now at
this point in your life yeah because I
don't want nobody around me
I don't trust people
you know I don't trust people and
another thing if I have somebody around
me and we're steady like kicking it and
we if I we fall asleep somewhere I'm not
gonna try I'm not gonna fall asleep or
I'm that person you know because I'm
gonna end up falling asleep first
because I've been I've been persuaded in
the comfortabilityness of people you
know what I mean and I had to get up out
of it like no hold on I'm good you know
they start flashing back I'm like oh man
so yeah it is it is
what would you say is your greatest
strength my greatest strength is
me honestly still still keeping my head
up still trying you know still trying to
heal from what I went through and see if
a different outcome comes like but it's
hard like it's depressing really bad
hey
and it's hard to explain to people
because nobody will really truly
understand the fact of what I went
through unless they've been through it
and a lot of people haven't been through
nothing like that
but I have
and it sucks
if you have dreams of doing anything
with your life when you were young yeah
I did I love photography photography is
my thing like I really like photography
and I like music too like
I like to make beats
too but that's always what I was when I
was young
photography I want to be a photographer
I want to take pictures I want to do
this I want to do that
you're so young
yeah
a little bit
only getting older
would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
the most important lesson I've learned
in life
is to
not make the mistakes I made then that I
would now and not the lesson I've
learned was what goes around comes
around you know and I guess I'm one of
those people who don't believe [__]
until it happens
another lesson two because it could go
all bad and karma karma fate and destiny
you know those are lessons too because
that [__] that goes around comes around
what goes up must come down
treat people how you want to be treated
that's just gonna come back and bite you
in your ass people always used to tell
me like my aunts and stuff I never would
listen because I was like why are you
telling me some good [__] when this bad
shit's happened to me within the family
like what are you doing you know giving
me a mind complex like what like
like but that's my biggest lesson in
life is
what goes around comes around so
make your best move your next move for
real
like your next move your best moves like
well really though because
you could go down the wrong path and
never turn back
and so that my biggest lesson in life is
I'm gonna I'm gonna have to stop and
think about things before I react or
stop and think before I speak I have to
start at baby steps again to make sure I
you know fully train myself like
properly like
because lessons or lessons like people
could be lessons or blessings and I've
had a lot of lessons in my life that I'm
done with like and I will never make
those mistakes again
it's crazy there we go thank you so much
for sharing your story
I wish you lots of luck out here
all right